♪♪
Welcome to
"Your Fantastic Mind".
I'm Jaye Watson.
This is a show where
we explore the mysteries
and the science of
the amazing human brain.
Have you ever
misplaced your keys?
Forgot a friend's
phone number?
Had someone's name on
the tip of your tongue?
Those things happen
to all of us.
But when Cecile Bazaz
was in her 40's,
a married mother in
the prime of her career,
she began to forget
more and more.
The doctor thought
it might be menopause,
but it was actually early onset
Alzheimer's disease.
It's one of
the few days in life
that calls for
an entire photo album.
Aww, this is
my favorite!
(Jaye Watson)
The day you marry
the love of your life.
In this case,
the Emory grad redhead Cecile,
who married the Englishman
new to America, Alister.
You like my
bouffant hairdo?
Yeah.
(Jaye Watson)
They are deeply
cherished memories
that have fled Cecile Bazaz.
The loss of her life,
of herself,
began when she was
just 49 years old.
When Alister and
Cecile's only daughter
was a sophomore in college.
(Kathleen Bazaz)
There had been little
signs along the way
that something
was going on.
(Jaye Watson)
Kathleen remembers a trip
to a nearby gas station.
Went to a gas station
close by our house
and, you know,
you swipe the card
and they ask you
to put in your zip code
and when Mom
did those functions,
she slipped in the card
and she was like,
"What's our zip code?"
I was like, "Mom, we've
lived in the same house
"for 20 years."
(Jaye Watson)
There was the business trip
where Cecile couldn't
use her laptop
because she didn't
remember her password.
Then she couldn't remember
what Alister and Kathleen
liked for breakfast.
All the seemingly
inconsequential things
that make up
a life falling away
for a once hugely successful
banking executive.
She confided in me
that she had a conversation
with her-her--
her manager at work,
who said that her performance
wasn't up to her usual standard.
I remember thinking, um,
it was very worrisome
that she could not perform
pretty basic addition easily.
(Jaye Watson)
Neurologist and Geneticist,
Dr. Thomas Wingo
was there the first day
Alister brought Cecile
to Emory Brain Health.
What they had hoped
were symptoms of menopause
were instead confirmed as
Alzheimer's disease.
I grew up really fast.
(Jaye Watson)
Kathleen spent
her college summers
babysitting her mother.
And then eventually
got to the points
where it's like,
I'm feeding her now,
or I'm changing
her diaper.
You know, never really
thought that I would be...
20 years old and
changing an adult diaper.
Um, I thought
that was something
that I would be doing
in my late 20s
when I had a kid
of my own.
(Alister)
We took the strategy of
we're gonna beat it.
And that's what kept,
I think, Cecile going
for a long-long time.
Was we figured we were
going to outrun it.
Either with, you know,
Allen, or somebody
discovering something that
would have beneficial results.
We got outrun by it.
(Jaye Watson)
Young onset Alzheimer's,
meaning onset on
or before 60 years old,
accounts for less than
1% of all Alzheimer's disease
thought to affect
50 in 100,000 people.
In 10% of young onset cases,
there is a family history.
A grandparent will have it,
then their child will have it,
then their grandchild.
With each generation
facing a 50% risk.
Dr. Wingo and his team
began research
to discover the cause
for the other 90%,
like Cecile,
who didn't have
a family history.
Although, she
did have a gene.
APOE e4, a variation on
the more common APOE e3,
which has been connected
to an increased risk
of Alzheimer's disease.
Wingo and his team
looked at the risk
of Alzheimer's disease
among parents and children
in 702 people
with young onset.
From 32 Alzheimer's disease
research centers
across the country.
They compared them
to over 5,000 people
with late onset Alzheimer's.
It really surprised us.
(Jaye Watson)
What surprised Wingo was that
among the 702 people
with young onset,
only between four
and eight percent
had a parent with
young onset
Alzheimer's disease.
But when they looked at
siblings of those patients,
almost 22% of them
had young onset as well.
How is it possible in
families with healthy parents
that more children
wind up with it?
(Wingo)
We were surprised to find
that the data suggested
that parents who were fine,
had carried one copy
of a defective gene,
but when--
and they passed it along
to a child that
inherited two copies
of this defective gene.
(Jaye Watson)
Wingo's Autosomal
Recessive Hypothesis means
each parent would have
a defective copy, or copies,
of a family of genes.
That defective copy from
each parent creates
young onset in
their children
who inherit both copies.
It's like a bad luck
lottery for two parents
to have copies of this
defective gene.
These mutations, um,
would have to be very rare
in the general population.
Say like 1% frequency.
Certainly less
than 5% frequency.
(Jaye Watson)
The human body
has 20,500 genes.
Wingo and his team don't
know the precise ones involved
but have narrowed
the search considerably.
Our sequencing to date
suggests genes that are
involved in cholesterol
metabolism.
(Jaye Watson)
If the specific gene or
genes could be identified,
it would point to new
biological processes
that could be treated.
Hope for treatment.
♪ I'm in love ♪
♪ ooh ♪
♪ I'm a believer
I couldn't leave her ♪
♪ if I tried ♪
♪♪
(Alister Bazaz)
Here you go, sweetheart.
Here you go.
You really fancy
your lunch today.
(Jaye Watson)
Everyday Alister visits
and feeds Cecile
at the Mann House
where she now lives.
I've got to believe
there's somebody in there.
And that's why I don't
think one should ever
give up on them.
♪♪
As much as it's caused so
much hurt in our family...
I think it's
brought us closer.
I'm just so amazed
and so proud
of the man that he is.
I'll play music
for you, love.
(Jaye Watson)
They play her
favorite music,
which sometimes elicits
a moving foot or gesture.
(Alister Bazaz)
You love this type of
music, don't you, sweetie?
I live by one standard,
is what would she
have done for me.
(Jaye Watson)
For Kathleen, now 29,
the future is sometimes
fraught with worry.
She has not been tested
to see if she, too,
has the risk copy
of APOE e4,
like her mother.
It's something that comes
through my mind probably...
once every couple days,
um, when I forget something
that I should, you know,
know right off
the top of my head.
(Jaye Watson)
And that's when she
thinks of her father.
His bottomless
loyalty and love
that he pledged
all those years ago.
For better or for worse.
I hope to choose
a partner in life that...
has seen this journey
and knows this journey
that we've been on.
And...
um, is willing to
go that extra mile
if that journey
comes along again.
(Jaye Watson)
It's predicted seven
million Americans
will have Alzheimer's by 2025,
six years from now--
a 35% increase--
an impending tsunami.
While young onset
Alzheimer's is only
a fraction of this number,
each breakthrough brings
scientists another step closer
to cracking the code
on a disease
that exacts an
unrelenting price.
We desperately need
not only individuals
but companies and governments
to get behind this,
'cause I-I can see a time where
almost every human being,
in the United States
at least,
and probably
the United Kingdom too,
will be connected to somebody
with this situation.
It'll be a brother,
it'll be an uncle,
it could be a wife.
There's no way you're not
gonna be able to say
I'm one step away from
somebody who's got it.
It's a family disease.
It's not an
individual's disease.
♪♪
Stories like Cecile's
are unsettling.
So now we're going to turn
to two of the leading experts
in the nation
on Alzheimer's
to give us
a reality check.
And to empower us with
the things that we can do
to reduce our risk of
Alzheimer's disease.
And the number of people
living to age 85 or older
is just going up
exponentially.
And that's really
the driving force
behind the tsunami of
Alzheimer's disease.
One out of every two or three
will have Alzheimer's disease,
or a related form
of dementia.
I always joke that, uh...
uh, one of the things
you can do is be
highly selective in your
choice of parents.
That's a critical factor.
♪♪
By the time
the symptoms begin,
that person's been
having already
a couple decade-long
journey with the disease.
And then that person might
live another decade
with slow progression.
♪♪
There's enormous overlap
in the risk factors
for Alzheimer's disease
and cardiovascular disease.
♪♪
It turns out aerobic
exercise is, uh,
gaining more
and more traction
in terms of, uh,
evidence for
its important role in
healthy brain aging.
♪♪
We tend to recommend,
um, what are generally
considered heart
healthy diets.
Fresh vegetables, um,
and fruits and nuts,
and light meats
and fish rather than
highly processed
and fatty foods.
♪♪
We've known for
a long time that
higher educational
attainment, um,
actually reduces your risk
of developing Alzheimer's
and related
dementing illnesses.
And we think that's
because the, uh,
the educational level
is sort of a--
a proxy or
a surrogate for,
um, for what you
wind up spending
most of your life doing.
So if you're pursuing
things that involve
a lot of thinking
and problem solving
and learning new things.
Um, that tends to, uh,
to be very stimulating
for the brain.
♪♪
The key time to be
focusing on lifestyle
is when you're
a young adult
and having healthy
lifestyle throughout
one's adulthood.
That's where the big impact
I think is likely to be felt.
It's gonna be very
hard to prove.
We don't do clinical trials
that take a lifetime.
Um, but, you know, what we're
learning is those things
are helpful for the
heart but they're also, um,
I think very likely to
be helpful for reducing
the risk of
Alzheimer's disease.
♪♪
I absolutely expect to see
that during my lifetime.
That, um, uh,
that people
who are in their
30s and 40s now,
I anticipate will, um,
be screening, um, for,
um, Alzheimer's disease
in their 50s or 60s,
so that, um, that they can
actually prevent themselves
from developing disease
or delaying it
for an extended
period of time.
♪♪
(Jaye Watson)
The one thing is coffee.
♪♪
I hated the bitter taste
when I was younger.
Now, I don't know how I ever
survived without it!
And countless millions around
the world agree with me.
Turns out, bitterness evolved
as a natural warning system
to protect us from
ingesting harmful things.
So, by evolutionary logic,
we should want
to spit coffee out.
But it turns out the more
sensitive people are
to the bitter taste of caffeine,
the more coffee they drink.
The sensitivity is caused
by a genetic variant.
Scientists with
Northwestern University
in Australia analyzed
previous research
of 439,000 people in the
United Kingdom
who did taste testing
exercises in other trials
and discovered this
adapted preference
for the bitterness
in coffee.
The researcher said,
people who have
that heightened ability
to taste coffee bitterness,
particularly, the distinct
bitter flavor of caffeine
learn to associate good
things with it,
such as the stimulating
effects of drinking it.
♪♪
Did you know that
babies in motion
cover a lot of ground?
(Dr. Karen Adolph)
Your average toddler is
taking 2,400 steps an hour
just in everyday play.
Um, they're falling
17 times an hour.
♪♪
(Jaye Watson)
NYU professor and psychologist,
Dr. Karen Adolph
is known for her 25 years
of research in the field
of infant motor development.
How babies learn how to move
all of their body parts.
Eyes, head,
hands, arms, legs.
(Jaye Watson)
Adolph's research has shown
that those well-known milestones
such as sitting,
and crawling, and walking
aren't connected in the way
that we think they are.
When, um, a baby first
learns how to sit.
If you perch that
baby at the edge
of a really big drop off
and offer a lure,
you know, from
three feet away,
"Hey, baby, can you lean out
over that drop off?"
They will just lean out
and tumble right in.
Over weeks and weeks
of sitting,
they get more
and more accurate
to where they seem
to really understand,
you know, this is how far
I can lean, um,
and if I lean too far,
I'm gonna fall
into that drop off,
so I'm not gonna do it.
If you test the same babies
now as a novice crawler,
they'll happily crawl
right over the edge
of the drop off
all over again.
Large and small.
What babies have learned with
an earlier developing skill,
doesn't help them.
It doesn't transfer to
a later developing skill.
So the fact that we put
all those skills on
the same milestone chart
doesn't mean that one thing is,
you know, kind of
inexorably leading to--
higher-higher up this, you know,
ladder to the next milestone.
(Jaye Watson)
Dr. Adolph and her team
have been awarded
a $6 million grant from
the NIH to create
a video data library of
infants and mothers at play.
The play and learning
across a year project
is a new kind of science.
Um, we're calling it
Synergistic Science.
So, this is a collaboration
among 65 professors
across the United States
and Canada
and the idea is
that together,
we will build
a corpus of data
about infant and mother
natural activity
in the everyday, you know,
world of their homes.
Um, just doing what
they naturally do.
This is the first time
that we can see
what really happens
out there in the wild
with babies
and their caregivers.
And then we can relate it
to health information
and demographic information
and senses check information.
(Jaye Watson)
The five year project will
provide even greater insight
into the lives and minds
of babies and toddlers.
There's never been
anything this, um, large.
Um, you know,
done at this scale,
this collaboratively
where we're really using,
um, the joint expertise
of a whole field rather
than the single expertise
of one, you know,
one researcher
in one laboratory.
It's giving us the first look
inside the life of a child
at these ages.
The friendships between
children as they head off
to preschool are some of
their first relationships
they have outside
their homes.
For children with autism,
education today often provides
a more inclusive environment.
But there's still
a long way to go.
At one school,
that inclusion
has been in place
for three decades.
And it's a model that can
create dramatic change
in all the students.
♪♪
(classroom chatter)
Sometimes it's tough to pick
your favorite part
of your day.
Now this story's a lot
like the last one.
(laughing)
But at Early Emory Center
for Child Development
and Enrichment,
sometimes it's easy--
Ruff-ruff!
Whee, wheee!
...to pick your
favorite person.
Sometimes he hugs me.
That's true.
Elise and Amiel...
You need to cut
those fingernails.
...are best friends...
And they're super pointy.
...whose relationship...
Well, I made the Ariel
picture for you.
Yeah, I never took
that home again.
...delights all
who know them.
Wow!
Four and a half.
No, you're four years old.
You're just four.
No, I'm four and a half.
(child)
One, two, three.
So, Amiel is five and a half,
and, um, he was diagnosed,
um, with autism
in March of 2014.
Exactly four years ago.
(Jaye Watson)
Amiel, like one-third
of the students
at Early Emory,
has autism.
Elise, like two-third of
the students does not.
(Dr. Michael Morrier)
Putting them together,
they learn how
to build meaningful
friendships with peers
that they may not
be otherwise put in.
And-- be put with.
(Jaye Watson)
Early Emory was one
of the first places
in the country in 1985 to
create this inclusive model.
Hi!
One in which
typical children
and children with autism
are together.
The curriculum mixes
developmental brain
science research
with early
education practices.
It's mixed into a day filled
with what children want to do--
play and learn.
Decades of research has
shown that having models,
typical kids, to imitate
and learn from,
actually changes the brains
of children with autism.
And with that, it is
changing the brain
and developing new
neural pathways.
Or changing neural pathways,
so that they're learning
to compensate for those
deficits due to the autism,
they're learning how
to make those up
and how to really get normal
social interactions.
Normal language
development.
(Jaye Watson)
This exposure to
incidental learning
can lead to
profound results.
About a third of children
with autism can eventually
become indistinguishable
from their peers.
With abilities to have
meaningful relationships.
For Amiel and Elise
it was simple,
they liked each other.
She liked me the
first time we met.
I think we liked
each other.
I think the first time we
met, we started to play
with each other, right?
Yeah.
I don't know what
day it was since--
We forgot what day
it was, right?
Could've been a Monday.
(collective chatter)
I was thinking
it's been awhile
since they've been
to the park, um--
Yeah, we should do that.
But they do lots
of playdates.
Yeah, yeah, we've gone to
the park together.
Yeah, yeah, several times.
(Jaye Watson)
Amiel's mom Rachel
says Elise is his first
real friend.
They were connected from
like the first day.
Amiel began by being
a good friend to Elise
who was new last year.
I feel like he did a great
job of reaching out
to her when she was new.
That's so sweet.
Yeah, and making
her feel comfortable
and helping her
make friends.
There's an honesty that happens
in the best friendships.
He goes wherever I go
because he likes me.
Well, sometimes I don't.
Friendships filled
with bows and boasts.
"Nothing left to prove.
Nothing left to prove."
The research has
shown something else.
Typical kids benefit as much
as the students with autism
but in a different way.
Most of them are
more empathetic.
They're not as noticing
of differences of other kids.
They have a lot more
compassion for people
and the research shows
that over and over again
for inclusion in general,
but especially when
they're including
the children with autism.
(Jaye Watson)
At four and a half
and five and a half,
these two teach us
that despite differences,
we can travel
the same path together.
Um, she has me back.
(teacher)
Go!
Run, run!
(laughing)
Kids don't see differences
the way we adults do.
A brief trip on social
media these days
shows you how divided
we can be.
Which is why it's good
to remember a simple truth,
we all want friends.
We all want to feel
included and supported.
In that way, Amiel and Elise
are teachers reminding us
that embracing differences
opens doors and minds
to friendship
and happiness.
That's gonna do it
for us this week.
We'll see you next time on
"Your Fantastic Mind".
♪♪